POLAND IS STEPPING IN AS
PRESSURE GROWS ON GERMAN TO
SUPPLY CRANE WITH THE BATTLE
TANKS.
OTHER COUNTRIES HAVE THEM AND
WANT TO SEND THEM BUT GERMANY
MUST SIGN OFF FOR THEM TO BE
TRANSFERRED TO UKRAINE.
DESPITE THE PRESSURE, BERLIN HAS
RESISTED DOING SO.
BUT THEY DO EXPECT A DECISION
SOON.
PRESIDENT ZELENSKYY SAID IT'S
URGENT.
>> Translator: THIS IS NO TIME
FOR BARGAINING.
THIS IS A TIME FOR SURVIVAL.
WE NEED TO SURVIVE.
>> POLAND'S PRIME MINISTER SAID
GERMANY IS WASTING TIME AND
UNTRUSTWOR
AND, QUOTE, WE WILL NOT PASSIVE
WATCH UKRAINE BLEED TO DEATH.
JOINING US IS JOHN BOLTON.
THE FIRST QUESTION HERE, DO YOU
BELIEVE GERMANY SHOULD SIGN OFF
ON THIS, ON THEM SENDING THE
TANKS AND OTHER COUNTRIES
SENDING THEM AS WELL?
>> I THINK THEY SHOULD SIGN OFF.
I THINK GERMANY'S PERFORMANCE
THROUGHOUT THE WAR HAS BEEN
DISAPPOINTING DESPITE THE
CHANCELLOR'S STATEMENT NEAR THE
BEGINNING THERE WOULD BE A SEA
CHANGE IN GERMANY'S DEFENSIVE
POLICIES.
IT HASN'T HAPPENED YET, IT HAS
TO HAPPEN.
>> DO YOU AGREE THAT THIS
DELIBERATION THE LAST SEVERAL
WEEKS IS, IN THE END,
>> OF COURSE IT IS.
IF THEY DON'T HAVE THE
CAPABILITY TO RESPOND TO
LONG-RUMORED, IMPENDING RUSSIAN
OFFENSES, THAT'S BAD FOR THE
UKRAINE, BAD FOR THE WEST AS A
WHOLE.
IT PLAYS INTO THE KREMLIN
STRATEGY TO WIN POLITICALLY WHAT
THEY CAN'T WIN ON THE
BATTLEFIELD BY SPLITTING NATO.
>> THE CHAIRMAN OF THE HOUSE
FOREIGN AFFAIRS COMMITTEE,
MICHAEL McCAUL SAID YESTERDAY HE
BELIEVES THE UNITED STATES
SHOULD SEND AN ABRAMS TANK, JUST
ONE, ALL THAT IT WOULD NEED TO
GREEN LIGHT GERMANY SPENDING THE
LEOPARD TANKS.
SHOULD THE BIDEN ADMINISTRATION
TAKE THAT STEP IN YOUR VIEW?
>> WELL, I THINK WE SHOULD DO IT
ANYWAY BECAUSE I THINK THAT'S
RIGHT FOR UKRAINE.
IF THAT BRINGS THE GERMANS
ALONG, THAT'S GREAT.
LET'S BE CLEAR.
WE NEED TO HAVE A CONVERSATION
WITH GERMANY SOONER RATHER THAN
LATER.
THEY NEED TO STEP UP TO THEIR
ROLE APPROPRIATE TO THEIR SIZE
ECONOMICALLY.
JAPAN ANNOUNCED IT'S GOING TO
DOUBLE ITS DEFENSE BUDGET IN THE
NEXT FIVE YEARS.
WHERE IS GERMANY?
>> ARE YOU CONCERNED WHAT IS
PLAYING OUT HERE WITH THIS
DECISION MAKES NATO LOOKS
FRACTURED?
>> WELL, I THINK NATO IS A LOT
MORE FRACTURED THAN SOME OF ITS
POLITICAL LEADERS WOULD LIKE TO
LET ON.
THERE'S BEEN A LOT OF PATTING
OURSELVES ON THE BACK.
LET'S NOT FORGET PUTIN THINKS HE
KNOWS THE GERMANS WELL.
HE WAS STATIONED THERE IN THE
KGB, AND I THINK HE SEES GERMANY
AS THE WEAK POINT IN THE
ALLIANCE.
>> I WANT TO MOVE TO THE
ANNOUNCEMENT THAT THE FBI
SEARCHED PRESIDENT BIDEN'S HOME,
WHICH THE WHITE HOUSE SAYS WAS
DONE IN COORDINATION WITH HIS
ATTORNEYS, NOT DONE WITH A
SEARCH WARRANT.
IT IS CONCERNING TO SEE THE FBI
GOING INTO THE HOME OF A SITTING
PRESIDENT TO SEARCH THAT.
WHAT DOES THAT SAY TO YOU ABOUT
THE SERIOUSNESS OF THE
INVESTIGATION INTO THE
CLASSIFIED DOCUMENTS THAT WERE
TAKEN?
>> I THINK IT'S GOING TO GET A
LOT MORE SERIOUS FOR BIDEN, THE
FACT THAT APPARENTLY SOME OF
THESE CLASSIFIED DOCUMENTS GO
ALL THE WAY BACK TO HIS SENATE
DAYS AND YET HAVE TRAVELED
AROUND WITH HIM.
IT'S AN INCREDIBLE GIFT TO
DONALD TRUMP THAT IN MANY
PEOPLE'S MINDS, NOT THE LEAST OF
WHICH ARE SENATOR DICK DURBIN,
SENATOR JOE MANCHIN, TWO
DEMOCRATS WHO SAID YESTERDAY
THEY THOUGHT THE ADMINISTRATION
HAD BEEN DAMAGED.
WE NEED TO DO A LOT MORE IN THE
TRANSITION PROCESS TO MAKE SURE
THESE CLASSIFIED DOCUMENTS GO
WHERE THEY'RE SUPPOSED TO GO AT
THE END OF AN ADMINISTRATION.
>> TRUMP HAS ARGUED THAT THE
JUSTICE DEPARTMENT IS TREATING
BIDEN DIFFERENTLY THAN THEY'RE
TREATING HIM.
IS TRUMP WRONG ABOUT THAT IN
YOUR VIEW.
>> WELL, THEY ARE TREATING BIDEN
DIFFERENTLY BECAUSE TRUMP
TREATED THE JUSTICE DEPARTMENT
DIFFERENTLY, AND THE TWO ARE NOT
EQUAL, THAT'S FOR SURE.
I THINK POLITICALLY BIDEN'S
SELF-INFLICTED WOUNDS HAVE
PRETTY MUCH ABSOLVE TRUMP FROM
THE PROSPECT OF PROSECUTION.
IT'S HARD TO PROSECUTE A FORMER
PRESIDENT TO BEGIN WITH.
I THINK BIDEN'S ERRORS HERE MAKE
IT ALMOST IMPOSSIBLE.
>> YOU THINK TRUMP WON'T BE
PROSECUTED BECAUSE OF WHAT'S
HAPPENED WITH BIDEN?
>> NOT ON THE DOCUMENTS.
NOW, THE JANUARY 6th
PROSECUTION, THE GEORGIA
INVESTIGATION, THOSE ARE
DIFFERENT.
BUT ON THE DOCUMENTS FRONT, I
THINK HE'S SKIPPED FREE AGAIN.
>> NOT EVEN ON THE OBSTRUCTION
FRONT?
THAT IS WHAT THE WHITE HOUSE HAS
DRAWN AS THE DISTINCTION, SAYING
WE'RE COOPERATING WITH THE
ARCHIVES AND THE JUSTICE
DEPARTMENT.
TRUMP FOUGHT THEM FOR A YEAR AND
A HALF THAT LED TO THE SEARCH OF
TRUMP'S HOME.
>> HERE IS KEY POINT.
WE ALL SAY AND IT'S RIGHT TO SAY
EVERYBODY IS UNDER THE SAME RULE
OF LAW.
NOBODY IS TREATED DIFFERENTLY,
BUT I WILL SAY THIS.
IF THE JUSTICE DEPARTMENT
INDICTS A FORMER PRESIDENT AND
FAILS TO GET A CONVICTION, THE
POLITICAL FIRESTORM THAT WOULD
ENSUE WOULD TARNISH THE
DEPARTMENT FOR YEARS.
YOU HAVE TO WEIGH THAT IN THE
BALANCE.
YOU CAN'T JUST BE SURE THAT YOU
THINK YOU CAN PROVE GUILT BEYOND
A REASONABLE DOUBT.
YOU BETTER DO IT.
IF YOU FAIL, TRUMP COULD RIDE
THAT TO THE WHITE HOUSE I'M
AFRAID.
>> SECRETARY POMPEO WHO YOU
SERVED WITH HAS WRITTEN A NEW
BOOK, MEMOIR, WHO IS DOWN RIGHT
SCATHING OF HIS ASSESSMENT OF
YOU.
HE WRITES JOHN BOLTON SHOULD BE
IN JAIL FOR SPILLING CLASSIFIED
INFORMATION.
I HOPE I CAN ONE DAY TESTIFY AT
A CRIMINAL TRIAL AS A WITNESS
FOR THE PROSECUTION.
HE SAYS YOURSELF-SERVING STORIES
CONTAINED CLASSIFIED INFO AND
DEEPLY SENSITIVE DETAILS
INVOLVING A SITTING
COMMANDER-IN-CHIEF.
WHAT'S YOUR RESPONSE TO
SECRETARY POMPEO?
>> WELL, WHAT HE KNOWS IN FACT
OR SHOULD KNOW IS MY BOOK WENT
THROUGH A FOUR-MONTH-LONG PRE
PUBLICATION REVIEW PROCESS
PRECISELY TO MAKE SURE THERE WAS
NO CLASSIFIED INFORMATION IN THE
BOOK.
IT WAS ARDUOUS AT TIMES I CAN
TELL YOU.
THE NATIONAL SECURITY COUNCIL
SENIOR DIRECTOR RESPONSIBLE FOR
THAT REVIEW CLEARED THE BOOK,
AND INSIDE THE WHITE HOUSE,
BECAUSE DONALD TRUMP DIDN'T WANT
THE BOOK PUBLISHED BEFORE THE
ELECTION, HE FIRED THE SENIOR
DIRECTOR, A CAREER EMPLOYEE OF
THE NATIONAL ARCHIVES FROM HER
JOB AND TRIED TO GET ANOTHER
REVIEW GOING.
AN INTERESTING POINT HERE, AND
THIS IS CRITICAL, BEFORE THE
JUSTICE DEPARTMENT WAS ORDERED
TO BRING THE SUIT TO STOP
PUBLICATION OF MY BOOK, THEY
INTERVIEWED THE SENIOR DIRECTOR
ELLEN KNIGHT FOR 18 HOURS OVER
FIVE DAYS IN THE WHITE HOUSE.
THEY MUST HAVE FORGOTTEN THE
THUMB SCREWS AND THE RUBBER
HOSES TO GET HER TO CHANGE HER
STORY, AND SHE WOULDN'T.
THE BOOK WAS CLEARED, AND I
THINK IF THERE'S AN
INVESTIGATIVE REPORTER THAT HAS
SPARE TIME, THEY OUGHT TO LOOK
AT WHO IN THE WHAUS AND
ELSEWHERE IN THE ADMINISTRATION,
IN THE COUNSEL'S OFFICE, THE TOP
POLITICAL LEVELS AT THE JUSTICE
DEPARTMENT FOLLOWED TRUMP'S
ORDERS TO TRY TO SUPPRESS THE
BOOK.
I'M NOT TALKING ABOUT THE LINE
ATTORNEYS AT THE DEPARTMENT OF
JUSTICE, BUT TRUMP'S TOP
ADVISERS WHO WERE CONTENT TO TRY
AND SUPPRESS IT.
>> YOU'RE IMPLYING THAT
SOMETHING ILLEGAL HAPPENED?
WHAT ARE YOU SAYING THERE?
>> WELL, REPORTERS SHELTER UNDER
THE FIRST AMENDMENT FREQUENTLY.
I'M SURE THAT'S MUCH ON YOUR
MIND.
THIS IS A CLASSIC EFFORT BY
TRUMP AT PRIOR RESTRAINT.
IN FACT, I WAS TOLD THAT A VERY
TOP JUSTICE DEPARTMENT OFFICIAL
ON HEARING THAT THE BOOK HAD
BEEN CLEARED SAID, AND I QUOTE,
ROUGHLY, I DON'T GIVE A BLANK
ABOUT THE FACTS, I WANT THE CASE
BROUGHT.
I THINK THERE'S A LOT THERE.
THIS IS ENTIRELY CONSISTENT WITH
TRUMP BEHAVIOR, TRYING TO
SUPPRESS OTHER BOOKS.
THAT'S WHAT HAPPENED HERE.
I THINK POMPEO KNOWS OR SHOULD
HAVE KNOWN ABOUT IT.
IF HE DIDN'T KNOW ABOUT IT, IT'S
INCOMPETENCE IN WRITING THE BOOK
FOR NOT CHECKING OUT THE FACTS
BEFORE HE PUT IT DOWN ON PAPER.
IF HE DID KNOW ABOUT IT, THAT'S
MALICIOUS AND WELL BEYOND
RECKLESS TO SAY THINGS LIKE
THAT.
>> AMBASSADOR JOHN BOLTON, THANK
YOU FOR JOINING US THIS MORNING.